You’re relaxing at home when there’s a
knock on the door.
You peer through the peephole and see a small
child with their hoodie obscuring their face.
You open your door and ask if they need help
but when they look up—you are staring into
black, lifeless eyes.
It’s not hard to figure out why these creatures
horrify us so much—it’s in their name.
Black-Eyed Children or Black-Eyed Kids, also
known as BEK, are modern monsters whose eerie
and unnatural appearance and behavior inspire
fear.
The unusual eyes are unnerving,
but it’s the age of these monsters that
really amps up the terror.
What is it about “evil” children that
freaks us out so much?
[Monstrum intro.]
The first report of a Black-Eyed Kid appeared
in 1998.
Texan reporter Brian Bethel wrote of an experience
he had two years prior while he was sitting
in his car near a movie theater.
Bethel claimed that his car was approached
by two boys around the ages of 9 and 12 wearing
hooded sweatshirts.
One appeared as an “olive-skinned, curly-headed
young man” and the other a “redheaded,
pale-skinned, freckled young man.”
Bethel opened the window a crack, and the
two boys asked for a ride to their mother’s
house to pick up some money so they could
see the Mortal Kombat movie.
To this day, Bethel recalls that when the
second one of the boys spoke he felt an unnatural
sense of dread.
He pointed out the movie had already started,
and they wouldn’t make it back in time,
but the boys began to push harder saying things
like “They were just two kids” and that
“They didn’t have a gun or anything.”
Bethel describes their voices as “mechanical”
and “rehearsed.”
The strange experience culminated in terror
when he realized each boy had black eyes,
“soulless orbs”—with no white showing
at all.
Understandably unnerved, he began to drive
away, but one of the boys banged on his window
and angrily cried “We can’t come in unless
you tell us it’s OK.
Let us in!”
Bethel sped off, and upon checking his rearview
mirror, he noted that the strange, black-eyed
children had completely vanished.
In 2013 Bethel wrote that his strange experience
with these children was originally shared
in a private communication with “a small
group of friends on an email list” that
then was leaked onto the Internet.
I couldn’t find any evidence of this original
document, but Bethel’s story is undoubtedly
the foundation of all BEK lore.
And that’s how an urban legend is born.
In eyewitness accounts and other stories,
the child-like creatures are frequently wearing
hooded clothing, although some versions claim
they are dressed in antiquated outfits.
They have odd speech patterns, black eyes,
and perhaps most importantly—they just don’t
act in a way we think children should.
Similar to some vampire legends, it appears
that they must be invited into a private space.
And to me this creepiness evokes fairy, demon,
and changeling vibes.
Though encounters tend to end without lasting
effects, some people who’ve had run-ins
with these creatures report nightmares and
agoraphobia.
Through the numerous interviews Bethel conducted
as his story circulated online, others across
the world began to speak up about their own
supposed experiences with other Black-Eyed
Children.
England in particular seems plagued by Black-Eyed
Children and they often serve as fodder for
tabloid magazines and newspapers.
Like in 2014, when songwriter and paranormal
investigator Lee Brickley was interviewed
by the Birmingham Mail about a sighting in
Cannock Chase, England.
The sensational story was quickly picked up
by the British and international press.
Brickley had been investigating rumored sightings
of a black-eyed ghost in Cannock Chase, including
one where a woman and her daughter were out
for a walk when they heard screams and spotted
a child wandering alone.
The mother ran to catch up but could not find
the child.
When she turned back around, a girl appearing
to be 10-years-old stood there with her hands
over her eyes.
She asked: Are you okay?
Were you screaming?
The girl just dropped her hands and revealed
eyes the woman said were “completely black,
no iris, no white.”
Startled, the woman grabbed her daughter and
jumped back.
When she looked up, expecting to see the child
- she’d vanished
Interestingly, Brickley also claims that this
same girl, whom he calls a “ghost,” had
been seen 30 years earlier in 1982 in that
same area by his own aunt, something he wrote
about in his 2013 book UFOs, Werewolves, & The
Pig-Man.
Brickley claims that his aunt heard a child
crying at night, and following the sobs, she
came upon a girl about 6-years-old who looked
up at her with completely black eyes, before
racing off into the woods.
Even a police search for the child turned
up nothing.
The sightings of this singular female BEK
in Cannock Chase may be connected to a real-life
tragedy that influenced Brickley’s identification
of the creature as a ghost.
Cannock Chase made headlines in the 1960s
as the site of one of the largest police investigations
in British history—the search for the murderer
of three local schoolgirls.
Some say the Black-Eyed Child of that area
is the ghost of one of the girls, and it would
make sense that a young female resident who
grew up with those stories would believe she
had seen something even if it wasn’t there.
As the urban legend of the Black-Eyed Children
evolved out of references to eyewitness accounts
of the monsters in the British and American
press, their presence across media of all
kinds exploded.
Numerous YouTube videos claim to show evidence
that such creatures exist.
The BEK also gained notoriety (and lore expansion)
through crowd-funded “fanfiction” texts
and productions like Sunshine Girl and the
Hunt for Black Eyed Kids, The Black-Eyed Children,
and Black Eyed Children: Let Me In.
The comic series B.E.K. expands the monsters’s
threat with the invention of a violent origin
story where regular children turn into Black-Eyed
Kids if they murder their family.
BEK are such great modern folklore because
they defy romanticized notions of childhood
and the inherent goodness of children—ideas
that have evolved over time.
The perception of children as innocent and
weak, requiring constant adult instruction
both morally and physically, is a relatively
modern invention.
Prior to the Romantic period, children were
largely socially insignificant.
They were background characters relegated
to chores and familial duties, and little
else.
Prior to the Romantic period, children were
rarely featured in Western literature, and
when they did they were often insignificant
background characters.
But with the progression of the Industrial
Age in the late 18th century, as infant mortality
declined, and literature and philosophy regarding
child education grew alongside
increased scrutiny around child labor—the
cultural concept of the child changed.
Childhood became a sacred cultural symbol,
a time of perceived innocence and happiness
when children were not valued for their usefulness
or economic viability but rather for their
hopeful possibility and vulnerability.
This continued to progress and evolve well
into the 20th century, when the seismic social
shifts following World War II changed everything.
Suddenly, youth culture and scrutiny of popular
media’s influence on children became hot
topics, and 1950s pop culture was flooded
with movies and literature showing “bad
kids” and juvenile delinquents.
Around this time, the theme of children being
born evil became a prevalent one, as we were
introduced to ever younger characters with
genetically inherited threatening characteristics,
like a desire to kill (The Veldt; The Bad
Seed) and mind-control (Village of the Damned).
Then through the 1970s and all the way into
the 90s we see a spike in horror texts with
children possessed by demons (The Exorcist)
or some other kind of evil entity (Pet Sematary).
They’re even portrayed as the literal offspring
of Satan (Rosemary’s Baby), or the Devil
himself (The Omen).
The examples from this time period seem pointed?
The rise of the child villain can be framed
in countless ways, including an emerging fear
of youth culture stemming from a movement
away from traditional, conservative ideas
by younger generations.
Others argue it’s a manifestation of Freud’s
“Oedipus Complex” where it is the Id,
the instinctual, unconscious part of the mind
of the child that wants to murder the parent.
Or “Peter Pan Syndrome” which locates
the child’s desire to kill in an attempt
to reject their own future as an adult.
And sure, as a generalized explanation for
the increase in fictional accounts of terrifying
children, these all make sense.
But none of that really explains the other
key feature besides age that makes the Black-Eyed
Children scary—those black eyes.
“The eyes are the window to the soul”
is a familiar saying.
We communicate with our eyes, and they serve
vital survival and social functions, so when
they appear unnaturally obscured, we become
uncomfortable—even scared.
Scientific research does show that we tend
to track the eye movements of others as an
evolutionary social mechanism.
Perhaps the inability to follow the gaze of
the BEK is what adds to their eeriness—and
the danger they threaten.
They could be looking anywhere—or nowhere.
Unfortunately, this concept was at one point
taken to the extreme with a practice called
physiognomy, which is predicated on the idea
that one’s facial features and eyes could
be “read” as a “natural language”
that would reveal insight about a person’s
character—or supposedly an indication of
their ethnic origins.
Needless to say, there was a lot of bigotry
and racism in the practice.
Although it’s roots date back to ancient
Chinese, Japanese, and Mesopotamian traditions,
the practice held prominent intellectual weight
in Europe until the eighteenth century.
Unsurprisingly, the eyes were the most important
feature to interpret.
According to a late 15th century text (De
homine, Galeotto Marzio 1490), eyes with no
whites visible were manifestations of unreliability
in a person.
There is also a larger cultural history of
dark eyes or black eyes being tied to inherent
evilness or an inner darkness, including many
racist depictions of non-white individuals
in literature, including children.
Dark or black eyes are also featured in evocations
of possession and demonic presence, and often
symbolize a lack of control.
To me, Black-Eyed Children are the— excuse
the pun—the offspring of four main thread:
One: our natural wariness of an obscured or
unusual gaze;
Two: intergenerational conflict;
Three: the legacy of malevolent children in
horror films;
and Four: the ease of which the Internet reinforces
urban legends.
The power of the internet to expand the reach
of these creatures cannot be overstated.
Historically, folklore and folk tradition
have been passed on through generations by
word of mouth and could even take years to
spread from one country or continent to the
other; but in modern times the world wide
web functions as a global town square, the
electronic equivalent of sharing stories by
the fire.
I know that personally, thanks to a combination
of The Children of the Corn and the French
film Them [2006], I am terrified of trick-or’-treaters.
Which yes, makes me somewhat of a Halloween
Grinch—but it also helps me understand why
stories of BEK continue to circulate.
Obviously, we know that my fear of trick-or-treaters
is largely irrational.
And we know that there aren’t soulless children
out there trying to kill us.
Right?
I mean, the Black-Eyed Kids are always trying
to breach the border from outside to.
From a public space with witnesses, to a private,
more solitary one.
Their faces are obscured, their eyes unreadable.
This particular urban legend seems to tap
into something deeper.
We are genetically programmed to care for
and protect the youngest of our species for
survival.
So when they are portrayed as sinister and
dangerous, it is deeply unsettling.
The world of BEK suggests that if you care
for children, they will kill you.
And if you ignore them, they will haunt you.